yes you read that title correctly apple
is working on the apple silicon imac pro
no it is not cancelled it is still an
active development according to mark
german who is the number one apple
leaker and he broke that information on
our channel in an exclusive interview
but not only that in this video i have a
bunch of other details to share with you
including a new source with some
exclusive leaks that just came out and
this stuff is getting very interesting
but before we get into those new leaks i
do want to mention exactly what mark
german said on the interview he said
that the imac pro is an active
development and it's coming as soon as
2023 which is next year or maybe it
could be in 2024
now this isn't the first time he's
mentioned that the imac pro is an active
development because back in april he did
say that the imac pro was being
developed but it would not launch any
time soon and then earlier this month in
july he said that apple is still working
on the pro imac with the larger screen
and he went as far as to say that it
could have a variation of the m3 chip
likely in m3 pro and m3 max which are
the chips that apple puts into their
higher end macbook pros the 14 and the
16 inch so i think the m3 max would be a
perfect fit for the imac pro however
that means it could get delayed until
2024 now in my opinion i think the
reason apple didn't release the imac pro
this year and they're holding off might
be because they're waiting for the more
efficient three nanometer process no
chips from tsmc to be ready which might
be why mark herman thinks it might be
the m3 pro or the m3 max now i actually
have a little bit of a different outlook
because we did get some reports saying
that tsmc is starting mass production of
new three nanometer m2 pro and m2 max
chips later this year and digit times
actually corroborated that statement
saying that the upcoming m2 pro chip for
the high-end macbook pros and mac mini
and of course the imac pro would be
based on the three nanometer process
note and i really hope this is gonna
happen but if it does not happen if
three nanometer has to wait until the m3
pro and max then in that case i think
this imac pro might wait until
2024 to come out because we're expecting
the regular m3 chip to come out late
next year and that's because according
to tsmc themselves they're saying that
they're starting the three nanometer
chips later this year and they're gonna
start shipping to their actual customers
like apple early in 2023 which would
make spring perfect for the launch of
the very first three nanometer chips
which i hope is the m2 pro and the m2
max now this brings me to some older
leaks from ming chi kuo when back in
march on march 10
he said this he said that the mac pro
the imac pro and the mac mini are going
to be coming out in 2023 yes all three
of those delayed which blew my mind and
i initially disagreed but guess what it
looks like he is right because mark
grumman on my interview recently he said
that the mac pro is not shipping till
next year and the imac pro is not
shipping till at least next year and
maybe even the mac mini if it comes with
the m2 pro chip that might not even come
until 2023 so it looks like ming chi kuo
was right all along i don't know how he
did it but he's right now getting back
to the actual imac pro leaks a lot of
them originated from ross young who last
year in october said that there is going
to be a 27 inch mini led display going
into an imac in the first quarter of
2022 and it's not going to be an
external monitor that may actually come
later but it would also have pro motion
technology and he even got a report from
digitimes confirming that the 27-inch
display was having some parts production
happening but of course that never
happened because later on in march on
march 9th he did say that it was getting
delayed and that delay was supposed to
happen until june which was basically
going to be wwdc and then going even
further in may it was delayed once again
saying that the 27 inch mini led monitor
which is now he's thinking just a
display not the actual imac pro would be
delayed as it has to go over to a
different factory because of the
lockdowns so now he said it's looking
like an october release and then finally
he went on the mac rumors podcast just
two weeks ago and said hey once again it
looks like it is being delayed and we
likely are not going to see it until
early next year and now with that said
let's finally get into our final
exclusive leaks that are the most
telling about this imac pro that we
should expect and it's of course from
amethyst on mac rumors forums and this
is actually the source who leaked the
max studio name
days before the actual apple march event
so a lot of the information he gave us
was confirmed so he's correct about that
and now he's leaking us information
about the mac pro like i talked about in
a video just a couple of days back and
he gave us some little teasers about the
imac pro as well back on march 4th even
before the event happened he said that
his pal has given him information about
a new high-end imac and then going even
further on march 10th he did reveal that
his friend had a prototype of the imac
featuring a 27 inch mini led display
which is exactly what ross young has
been reporting for a long time like this
commenter mentioned right here and then
on march 11th he gave us a full post
talking about the different prototypes
that his friend had with the larger imac
he said that last year there were three
prototype big imacs the first one used
an old intel chassis so the old design
the same 27 inch panel but an m1
processor so apple was actually testing
apple silicon with the original m1 with
that old chassis in a prototype then he
got the second one around last august
2021 which actually occupied the 24 inch
chassis style which is the new redesign
but with a 27 inch panel and still the
m1 processor but then the one that came
recently in last november came with the
new design a 27 inch new mini led xdr
panel and an m1 max chip so that is the
latest one that's the one that we
thought we were gonna get but it
ultimately probably got scrapped and the
big point he said that worried him was
that his pal said that at the start of
this year there were no more prototypes
but he still believed that the big imac
is not dead he was just worried that
there was no sign of a new prototype so
maybe that's what happened with apple
scrapping it and then of course all that
info was shared on a new mac rumors
article by jorah signal but the biggest
detail that matters a lot about this 27
inch imac is that it actually had a
black finish with the new redesign which
shows that this will be an imac pro for
sure it's going to be higher end and
it'll probably have the m2 max chip with
this new mini led display so from mark
german we know it's in active
development we know it's got a black
finish we know it's got the new redesign
with a new 27-inch mini led panel which
matches up to what ross young was saying
all along the only thing we don't know
is when it's coming so hopefully it
comes next year at some point maybe the
spring or the summer the fall who knows
hopefully but if it doesn't it could get
delayed until 2024 if it ends up having
the m3 max and pro chip instead so i
guess we're gonna have to see but if you
enjoyed all this info i gave you guys in
this video let me know down below and
click the circle above to subscribe and
by the way thank you for a million
subscribers definitely check out those
two videos right there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]